And a common question when coming to Unreal Engine,
it can sometimes feel a lot to think,
okay, I know about all this data,
but where do I use it and how do I use it?
So there's a lot of blueprint communication going on here.
You'll see different wires connecting to different elements
and it can get a little bit overwhelming.
So let's try and demystify some of this.
So essentially you can put any data wherever you like
you know, maybe we should caveat this.
It definitely not is a one size fits all
and maybe we shouldn't say that, but on the whole,
yes, you can put the data wherever you like,
but let's kind of set a few guiding principles
of what might be good practice.
So what are the things do I need to access this data?
Like the blueprint communication,
like if the controller is connected to the character,
then I can pass things along quite easily.
But if there are two actors
that aren't currently connected with each other,
does it make accessing two bits of data accessible easy?
Possibly not.
So how long do I want this data to live for?
You remember that the game instance is spawned at runtime
and then destroyed again.
So if you want something to persist,
maybe the game instance isn't the right place to put that.
And what other context might the data accidentally end up in?
So, you know, if you're trying to store player lives
and you put the player lives on the character,
but then you also put it in maybe the game instance
and then you have a class that's called player lives
and you might start get accidentally overwriting
other bits of information, things could get messy.
So you kind of just want to think a little bit
about your architecture when you start.
Maybe asking yourself these three questions as you go
and that will help you organize your information.
So with the Pawn, for the duration of the Pawn,
it lives up until the level is destroyed
or destroyed by the game logic.
So multiple Pawns can be used
in one level and play session.
And, you know, something that the Pawn stores
is its capabilities and interactions.
So, you know, can it run, walk or fly
or can it interact with a door or something like this?
These are the kinds of things
that you want to put on the Pawn class.
There's some useful ways to get the Pawn data
and set the Pawn data.
So you'll see quite a common event that's in red here
on the image that's called event actor begin overlap.
And this is, you know, a standard trigger
inside of Unreal that detects something
that overlaps the trigger.
And you'll see that it says other actor with a blue pin.
And it's asking what just overlapped me?
Like, I am a trigger, what just overlaps me?
And it checks to see if this is a Pawn.
And if it's a Pawn,
then you can get some of that Pawn's data.
Maybe you want to say,
is the Pawn currently swimming right now
or something like this?
I don't know what conditional check you want to do,
but you have that information there to check against.
You can also get the player Pawn
and you can also get the controlled Pawn.
So get, look, remember to look out for the player index
because if there's multiple players
then getting player Pawn might return many values.
So zero will be just the first Pawn in the map.
So player index zero.
But if you get the controlled Pawn,
you will always get the Pawn
that the player is controlling.
So worth keeping those things in mind.
For the controller, again, the level of the controller
lives until the level is destroyed.
And it's not really expected to be destroyed
because the controller essentially is the player.
If you think when we're talking about the brain concepts,
you don't really want the brain to get destroyed
because it often outlays the Pawn.
The Pawn might die and the Pawn might get destroyed,
but you as the player still want to have a controller
to even things like using the menu system
that would still be run through some type of controller.
So the Pawn might get killed, for example, in a game,
but you might just possess a new Pawn
and the controller would still be persistent.
So this essentially relates to anything
that is the player or an AI.
Remember, it's a brain,
so the AI would still need a controller.
And so we might hold things like the score or kill count,
or do you have health there?
Again, you could store that in the character.
I don't want to get too in the weeds
of where you can store each things,
but it is data agnostic in that respect.
So just thinking about these concepts
and how long the controller lives for
is useful for when to store information.
So to get the controller,
we can just get the player controller,
we can get controller.
So that might be an AI controller that we want to get,
and then you can get the owning player as well.
So there's a few types of ways to get the player,
well, the controller in general.
Coming to the game mode.
So like we said, the game mode is a single instance
that exists before the level
and persists as long as the level hasn't changed.
So we can just get the game mode,
very simply on the level blueprint,
we can just do get game mode.
And this is essentially useful for getting information
for the level that's currently being played.
It can be classed as more long-term data,
which might span across multiple players,
or be a single set of data
that multiple entities need to get access to.
Say there's a world clock or something like this
that multiple players might need to know about.
We've got the game instance.
So the game instance spawns when you press play,
and then as soon as you exit the level,
the game instance will go away.
So the game instance,
you wouldn't really contain data
that relates to a particular level or current events,
it's just needed to store
any kind of currently runtime information.
And you can simply just get the game instance again,
like the get game mode, just get game instance.
And if you have a specific game instance
that you've created, if you get the game instance,
then you can cast to the name
of your specific game instance
to return some kind of variable from that,
that game instance that you've created.
So the HUD and HUD widgets, slightly different,
but the HUD is spawned alongside the player controller,
but it can be replaced at runtime by a function call.
The HUD widget is in control of the player,
but will be deleted on level close.
So this is essentially the internal state
of handling any UI elements, animations, current displays.
You can reference it across actors,
but again, you can store HUD widgets,
like we said before in a porn or a player controller,
you can just create a widget inside of these classes.
So you don't necessarily just have to use this class,
but if you are using the class,
you can just right click, get HUD,
and that will return the HUD that you might want to cast
to that the player currently has set.
The level blueprint, as we said,
lasts for as long as the level is loaded
and you might just have a very level specific scripts
in which we already covered, you know,
in the door example that I mentioned
on the level blueprint.
The level blueprint should listen for changes
and orchestrate events.
So any kind of, you know, gameplay scripts
in that happens throughout the level,
say the player does open this door
and you want to listen for the door opening
and then call a different event,
something like that is why you'd use a level blueprint,
but you can really get or set any specific data
on the level blueprint.
You wouldn't really want to take that approach.
It's more just for the moment to moment scripting
of a level blueprint, like in the examples we gave.
You can make your own actor components.
This is more advanced.
So you don't need to do this.
This would be more for maybe technical designers
and technical artists and maybe more engineers.
But when the data does need to be reusable
and exist on several different actors,
you can create blueprint actor components
from the content browser.
So that might be something you want to look into.
It doesn't just need to be in the C++.
You can create blueprint actor components
and you can also make your own manager actors.
So for example, if you're making a racing game
and you want to store all the races
and the current score and some kind of manager
that manages the race,
you would put this in just one per level
and it just organizes everything into one place,
which can be helpful.
It can just be an empty blueprint class
that is loaded on the level as well.
So just thinking about the architecture there is very useful.
And just to close out,
if you are new to Unreal Engine,
there is a great, great function to use.
It's super secret.
Nobody talks about it, but everyone talks about it.
It's this node here.
So you'll very quickly stumble upon this function
as your Unreal journey unfolds.
And it's a very useful kind of get all access of class.
So, you know, you might be looking for a certain player,
but you don't have a reference to the player.
So you just want to get all access of class
and you think, oh, does this one player exist?
So I'll just get everything
and then just return the first player
and that will be my player and I'll do something with it.
So you can do this for prototyping.
It can be helpful,
but it's a very heavy handed function to use.
It can be not the most optimized way to do things.
It can also cause bugs.
So just use it sparingly,
I think is the best recommendation there.
It's similar to how Tic exists on a level blueprint
or blueprints, should we say.
And you can access Tic for a number of reasons,
but you just want to use these kinds of things sparingly
because especially if you're working in games in production,
these are more heavy handed ways to do things
and maybe better used in quick prototypes
and just things that you're trying to get mocked up
quickly just to demonstrate a behavior.